how long was that shoot I watched it by
the way it was excellent I loved how
there was heart in it and and it was
based on something that you kind of
experienced herself in a waiting room
somewhere that's true I I experienced
the car wash I got the idea for it
because I was sitting in a car wash one
day and one elderly lady looked over at
me and said one brief sentence about
loneliness how she was just lonely and
want someone to talk to and we didn't
really go much past that but that stuck
in the back of my head while I was
writing the screenplay and we actually
shot the car wash into six hour days
which was really intense because it's
very dialogue driven almost like a
one-act play and to do that it was very
important to be very efficient and quick
because with EDA if we had a very
limited amount of time to work with her
and we also had ten pages of script to
go through and something that's dialogue
driven it's very much about the
performance and how you block the
performers to get the dialogue maximized
for the viewer and so that probably was
the most challenging thing to working
with a 12-hour shooting period
so when you say blocking I know she was
sitting down in I believe all of the
films right so how how are you figuring
out things around that just someone
that's sitting in one spot
sure well as a working with my
cinematographer on that project who was
also college age student like myself you
know this was the most challenging thing
we'd ever done because I thought as a
college student when I was writing the
screenplays some of my peers were
writing projects that were way too
ambitious for what we had the capacity
to do you know they're writing scenes
that had visual effects and they were
doing things that had action sequences
and I felt like as a director at a
college age that I did not have the
resources or capacity to direct
something like that so to do something
character-driven something that was
someone sitting down someone in a
contained space I thought that I had a
better opportunity to make something
that would
work better at that time in my career so
the way we blocked it I was trying to
figure out how can we make this
compelling from the standpoint of the
dialog because while my favorite
filmmakers are Sidney Lumet who directed
my favorite film Network and I think
about that film a lot when I'm looking
at compositions of scenes how to set up
a scene a way that motivates the
dialogue and the performance and so in
the car wash I wanted to start wide and
get closer and closer and closer and
closer as the film got more intimate
because I thought that would be a way to
better communicate what was going on
with the character and so in doing that
it enabled us to have a simpler process
to maximize our shooting schedule but
also to divide and block out the script
in a way that made sense dramatically so
$1,000 and that's what it took to take
for her two days being there was that
your own money that was my own money I
you know in the early days I saw
financed a lot of my work I would do
weddings I would do I did children's
audiobook I did anything I could find to
finance the projects I wanted to work on
so I could buy a camera buy a microphone
now it's different now this was like
2006 and didn't like 2007 now you have
smartphones that can shoot 2k or 3k with
certain apps but we didn't have that
back in the early days of the 2000s you
know we had to buy expensive DV cameras
or cheap DV cameras that didn't have
very good quality and then you'd have to
buy the thousand dollar or Final Cut Pro
System to work with it and the laptop
that could handle it it's a lot more
expensive then and so I just would find
any way I could to buy those pieces of
equipment and to buy those pieces of
software so as my storytelling developed
that I could do better things
you